I'll be going into spoilers since Avatar
the way of water has been out for a
couple of weeks so we can talk about the
story in detail obviously the biggest
draw for the movie is the visual side of
production and that is all outstanding
I'm sure you've heard about that ad
nauseum and this aren't much to add in
that regard so despite looking at this
movie from a negative perspective I
don't hate it by any means and just want
to open up a discussion about the story
The reason why I want to focus on the
story of Avatar the way of water is
because the movie has been in
development for over 10 years so surely
in that time the script should be pretty
Rock Solid but that didn't feel like the
case when watching it from there being
rough dialogue where the new story
mechanics some baffling plot points and
an overall script that gives off the
feeling of James Cameron having free
reign and no higher-ups having the balls
to address different issues within the
script I'll bring up some examples for
all these points in a second and before
doing that I want to draw a comparison
to the first avatar people have famously
called the movie unoriginal and it was
just Pocahontas but with the alien
however because of that simple and
effective plot it translated really well
into this new setting and because of
this the first avatar wasn't held back
by the story this is where I think one
of the major components of Avatar the
way of water feels off to me because in
the first movie we had a compelling
protagonist go through a riveting
Adventure laced with Whimsical and
exciting World building while being
anchored by a strong Love Story along
with having the feeling of escapism
through Jake leaving his dour life on
Earth where he can't walk to a vibrant
life on Pandora in which she can
transcend anything he could do on Earth
it was very liberating in a way in the
way of water I feel like we are missing
the strong through line that carries the
movie the substitution here is Jake's
family but I don't think it's as strong
as the wonder like awe the first avatar
was able to capture that's kind of here
with the beautiful visuals but not
narratively the characters that we
follow have very little character
development and the main emphasis is on
the spectacle to me this creates a
feeling of disconnection because instead
of having a symbiotic relationship
between dazzling visuals and good
character work we instead have minimal
character work with a stronger emphasis
on visuals during certain segments of
the movie it felt like I was watching an
hour-long version of the ride flight of
passage in Animal Kingdom it was more
like an experience rather than an
engrossing story and again that
experience was very fun but you don't
have to sacrifice the story and just
have scenes solely there for the sake of
spectacle instead you could do both like
in the first avatar another thing is
that Jake Sully and atiri take it
backseat and it's Siri More Than Jake in
that regard so that their kids can take
center stage now this would be fine in
theory if the kids were as interesting
as Jake and natiri were in the first
movie to me this isn't the case firstly
going into the bad dialogue Jake's kids
are talking as if there are some weird
human kids saying bro and cuz in every
other sentence this was very jarring to
say the least and it doesn't give off
the notion that these are Navi now I
know that they have a human father
figure but I find it weird for Jake to
teach his Navi children human slang
words that not even kids use that often
it feels like James Cameron is out of
touch with how kids sound let alone
alien kids you'd think that natiri would
want them to be more skewed toward Navi
culture and would probably dislike that
then moving away from the dialogue the
kids in most scenes didn't come across
as that likable the two brothers had an
extremely basic older younger brother
Dynamic and were constantly coming
across as arrogant that's fine at times
but when they're putting themselves in
Mortal danger to the point where they
need to be saved in every other scene
then it becomes annoying narratively
like the kids were taking prisoner on
three separate occasions once in the
First Act and then twice on the boat
there was a point in the end where they
were like we have to intervene and they
take their youngest sibling with them
for literally no reason I was extremely
confused by that decision because she
offers no value and they are necessarily
putting more of their family in danger
the two child characters that I thought
were more interest thing where spider
and Curie for Kiri it was kind of hard
for me to get over the fact that she was
being played by a 73 year old Sigourney
Weaver but she never came across as
overly annoying the mechanic in which
they can control certain parts of the
world of Pandora was the cold direction
to take her then the inherent nature of
spiders Dynamic of being a human raised
by the navi was fascinating then to have
him be captured by his resurrected
Avatar father korich throws on another
complex Lair that in turn makes for some
good scenes the only issue here plot
wise for this character is at the end of
the movie throughout the course of
spider's Journey he sees how ruthless
and cruel quartz is to the navi there
are some brief moments where he kind of
bonds with his father and opens up a bit
with him but that gets drastically
overshadowed later on by the horrifying
things quartz does also it feels pretty
underdeveloped how an interior was so
quick to kill a spider during the
hostage negotiation in the beginning the
writers kind of drop it and don't
address it again seems like this would
be something that would heavily affect
spiders loyalty so the ending in which
spider saves quartz's life seems pretty
confusing overall and it feels like he's
dooming the fate of the navi in the
process despite the movie giving off the
notion that he's so loyal to the navi
I'm sure a lot of people face palm
during this moment and it feels like
James Karen wants to keep this villain
character around although this will kind
of be getting into the wonky news story
mechanics because in theory wouldn't
they be able to endlessly bring back
these characters in Alien avatars given
that they can now suddenly throw a
retcon download the minds of human
beings as if this is altered carbon
suddenly seems like a crazy McGuffin to
just Breeze over pretty quickly in the
beginning like they can dead ass just
copy anyone's mind now what the hell is
the point of this dumb orange goo that
they're mining from the brains of tolkun
that holds your aging when you can just
be cloned which the orange goo is also
insanely absurd that an entire vial is
only worth 80 million dollars we live in
a world currently where there are Ultra
billionaires let alone the future where
these people will become even more
obscene rich like Bill Gates can buy
about 1300 of those vials right now and
can basically use them as His morning
routine face lotion so that new mechanic
was really silly but I don't see the
point of this if humans in the story can
make avatars of aliens then shouldn't
they be able to do so for humans I would
assume that would be at least easier so
then what would be the point of buying
age lotion when you can transfer your
mind into a new body I know this is
something relatively minor in the grand
schema thing is to get caught up on but
these World building story elements
don't add up and when your world doesn't
consistently make sense then it will
come across as faulty this wasn't as
much of an issue in the first avatar
because it didn't have conflicting
elements unobtanium was kind of a meme
but it worked as a baseline for the
antagonist to pursue however in the way
of water being able to easily clone
people and copy their minds contradicts
the need for the orange glob of the
Aging this is a big problem to me
because this is the main objective of
the antagonist then going into some
other weird plot points is that the
humans now want to colonize Pandora this
sounds pretty ridiculous because firstly
why would humans pick a planet with no
oxygen and that also has a hostile
population that they will have to fully
exterminate to live in wouldn't it be
easier to pick a different planet at
this point like it made sense in the
first movie to go to Pandora because it
was rich and unobtanium and they were
just there to mine it but to choose to
live there seems like an odd Choice it
just feels like James Cameron is forcing
the humans to come back on very slim and
unrealistic motivations just so that we
could have this conflict so reworking
their motivations and reasoning for
being there seems like a given and it
can be as simple as there's no more on
obtainium on Earth and they need it on
Pandora and that's why they came back
not to live there permanently and
instead to essentially wage war on
Pandora for all its resources I know
that James Cameron is making a statement
about how the Earth is dying and we need
to find a new planet but when you have
the means of interstellar travel then
surely we'd have more options than just
panda Dora then to list off a couple of
other weird plot points are to see
people disappearing halfway through the
third act when the eclipse happens and
then Jake saying that he needs to
protect the forest Navi Clan by leaving
and then he just joins a new clan that
he then endangers with his presence
seems like a forced way to get to the
Sea I'm also kind of surprised that the
humans didn't care at all about the
forest Clan and only pursued Jake then
one last thing in regard to the script
is that the movie really didn't need to
be over three hours a lot of the scenes
felt pretty extended and could have been
shortened a little although it is really
nice to have some breathtaking visuals
to gawk over it's just that as I said
before you need to be more productive
and have plot progression that coincides
with the spectacle the structure of the
movie also feels a little lopsided
because the First Act was pretty fast
paced in comparison to the long second
act it's pretty apparent that James
Cameron wanted to get to the Sea as soon
as possible then there's one scene that
could probably be deleted in which
quartz's team wants to tame Mountain
banshees the reason why I say this is
because because they don't really
utilize them after this because they
just joined the big ship and park them
for the rest of the movie choir says
briefly use it during the final act
against Jake but you don't need that
small moment in an already big action
set piece this is why I think the
producers were scared to stand up to
James Cameron because there's some fluff
here that could have been cut out
considering that the movie is 3 hours
and 12 minutes I know I've been talking
about all the negatives within the story
but there are still some shining
positives my favorite parts are
definitely the strong emotional moments
between Jake and interior that really
carried the movie at times Zoe Saldana
in particular really blew me away with
her performance and I'm pretty sad that
she wasn't in the movie all that much
then the whale poaching was so
heartbreaking the movie really gets you
to love the tolkan by making them
friendly and sentient creatures making
the aspect of humans hunting them even
more depressing definitely a great
element in the story that was kind of
tarnished by the orange goo aspect
overall the story for Avatar the way of
water feels like a step down in
comparison to the first avatar which I
was kind of surprised by it doesn't feel
as coherent and solid as the first movie
and I feel like the script needed a
little reworking despite being in
development for so long but the action
was stunning and the VFX will easily win
an Oscar with no competition despite the
lackluster story I'd still give it a 3.5
out of 5 on letterboxed thank you for
watching and let me know what you
thought about Avatar the way of water